let me also inform you that you will be
able to request to catch the eye
and blue card interventions via your
voting machine
after you have inserted your voting card
so i would therefore invite you always
to bring your voting card to the hemi
cycle
instructions in fact have been made
available to you should you wish to
register for catch the eye you should
start doing so now
can i please ask your dear colleagues to
keep silent on your way out
i also want to remind you that
interventions in this chamber will
continue to be made from the central
rostrum
okay except for the catch the eye blue
cards and points of order so i kindly
invite you to keep an eye on the
speaker's list and to approach
the rostrum when you're speaking time is
imminent
so i give the floor now to the president
of the european council charles michelle
to take the floor
but i once again asked colleagues
not to make noise when exiting the
chamber
president michelle you have the floor
madam president of the european
parliament
madam prince of the commission
dear members of the european parliament
one month of war
one month of death
destruction
and suffering
one month
of russian terror against the people of
ukraine
and one month
of the democratic world rising up with
full force to condemn russia
and to stand against this barbaric and
immoral war
mario paul
like other cities
mariopol
will forever be engraved in the history
of
tones
a theater bumped
an art stuart bumped
where so many people took refuge
ninety percent of the city damaged or
destroyed
residents
held hostage by russian troops
no food
no water
no electricity
no heating
mariopol
one month ago
a vibrant city
and today
in ruins
dear colleagues
russia is responsible for this war
russia alone targeting women children
civilians
these are crimes
and those responsible will face
international justice
no impunity
ladies and gentlemen
we are not alone in condemning this
brutal war far from it
the eu
along with our partners and allies is
rock solid in our solidarity for ukraine
for one month an international coalition
has risen up to denounce this war
nations
businesses citizens the united nations
together
have one common goal to defeat vladimir
putin
putin thought he would conquer ukraine
in a few days and he was wrong
he thought he would divide the eu and
our allies and he was wrong
because the people of ukraine are
fighting bravely defending their homes
and the future of their children
defending their
democracy and defending
our european command values
the european union with our allies we
stand as one and we are taking action
against the kremlin
with our international partners we have
imposed the heaviest sanctions we have
ever adopted
hitting the financial system
crippling key economic sectors
and cracking down on supporters of the
regime
freezing russia's throwing reserves
banning banks from swift
the ruble has plummeted multinationals
are flying a flinch and sanctions
russian companies and on decision makers
propagandists oligarchs
freezing
freezing the eu assets
banning their travel in the eu
targeting
the yacht
the villas they private jets
and we are implementing these sanctions
and working to close the loopholes that
provide an escape for russia
and
we are prepared to do more to staff
putin's war machine
ladies and gentlemen
as we speak
the ukrainian people are battling for
their freedom
and will not abandon them because this
is our political and moral duty
they are fighting not only for
themselves but they are fighting for our
common values and principles
in versailles two weeks ago
we decided to increase our humanitarian
political financial and material support
to ukraine
over 3 million people have fled to the
eu
mostly women and children
and we are welcoming them with dignity
and will continue to offer them any
assistance they need and show solidarity
with the countries on the front line
and will also continue
to provide military equipment to ukraine
with one billion euro already mobilized
through the european peace facility
we also have
a very powerful tool in our association
agreement with ukraine
and we must make the most of it
just last week we continued our support
in the energy sector by connecting
ukraine and moldova to our european
electricity
grid we have also worked
intensely on the diplomatic front to try
to end this war
president macron
and chancellor schultz have also played
an important role in our diplomatic
efforts and i speak to president
zelinski nearly every day and i've
spoken we've been in putin multiple
times and the goal is clear this war
must end
our ukrainian friends
are also asking for another kind of help
this is political help
ukraine is part of our european family
and we agreed to support the european
choice of ukraine and its right to
choose its own destiny
we have decided to immediately
strengthen our bonds and deepen our
partnership and to support ukraine in
pursuing its european path
we have proposed to launch a ukraine
solidarity trust fund and an
international adonis conference to
provide support to ukraine for its
immediate needs and to help rebuild a
free and democratic ukraine
ladies and gentlemen we will have the
opportunity to talk about this at the g7
summit and the european council tomorrow
now a few points regarding the
versailles agenda which i think
breathes new life into the whole issue
of european sovereignty
we all know
that the european project is about peace
and prosperity that is the promise it
holds now in the european council we
want to make sure that we turn the
european project and prosperity into
reality we have to factor in the climate
agenda the digital agenda and we know to
what extent
coveted put a lot of pressure on us and
it revealed our flaws and our
shortcomings but of course it also
showcased solidarity and the ambition
that we have for our european agenda in
versailles we pinpointed our flaws and
our strengths and we have come up with
an agenda and our working method in
order to push ahead and we want to work
hand in hand with the commission and the
parliament there are three points that i
would like to focus on
the first point is something that we
have discovered brutally we have huge
problems with
energy weakness and of course this is
linked to our green deal choices and our
ambition to be more independent in the
future but we mustn't wait because
climate neutrality has to happen now we
have to adopt the right measures we have
to look at resilience we have to look at
independence and we have to extricate
ourselves from our dependence especially
on russian gas and this will really be
at the heart of our debates tomorrow and
the day after in the european council
the second issue is also
obvious and that is security which is
linked to peace and so this is linked to
europe and the europe of defence for
years now some voices have been
clamoring
for
european countries to work together in
order to
boost their european defense
capabilities we've got some initial
tools that have
been put into place but now it's obvious
that we have to change tack we have to
move up a gear and i firmly believe that
this bold decision taken by the 27
european leaders
linked to peace facility in order to
deliver military equipment clearly shows
that if we want to europe can have a
real ability to bring its influence to
bear in order to promote peace and our
values and then ladies and gentlemen the
third point that i would like to raise
is linked to the robustness of our
economic base we have to adopt measures
that deal a blow to
the russian regime and we can do that
because we are
have a strong internal market with 450
million consumers we have many strengths
and advantages but we have to be
clear-headed there are shortcomings
there are weaknesses that we have to
deal with immediately and that's what
we're going to be doing working
hand-in-glove with the council and the
commission and i hope also with the
european parliament uh
chips microprocessors
these are technology related issues that
we're going to have to look at and that
will have a bearing on innovation
health as well we've seen to what extent
the whole issue of health has an impact
on our collective uh
welfare and prosperity and how it is
linked to our economies so we're going
to continue working on this and push
ahead
madam president you can see this and
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
there is no doubt that the last few
years haven't been easy for europe and
the world
we have had digital trans transformation
global crisis global pandemic that has
dealt a huge blow to us but we have
resisted and we've tried to draw lessons
especially those linked to economic
recovery and the ability to work
together
we
also woke up a month ago to a different
europe to a different world because once
again
war is unfolding on european soil
we are fully aware of our responsibility
we have to rise to the occasion because
we're fully aware of the fact that the
decisions that we take today have to be
intelligent have to be strategic
so that we can make sure that we rise to
the occasion and rise to the promise of
the european union linked to peace and
prosperity thank you
[Applause]
thank you president michelle i give the
floor now
to the president of the european
commission also love on the line
thank you madam president mr president
honorable members
every day we watch and horror the images
coming from besieged ukrainian cities
the devastation of mario paul kharkief
and the outskirts of kiev
but let me take you for a moment beyond
the front line into occupied ukraine
after the siege and the shelling the
reality of occupation is just as
terrifying fresh food has become a
luxury
hospitals and pharmacies are running out
of medicines
hundreds of people have been detained by
russian occupation forces
and yet every day
thousands of ukrainians keep taking the
streets to protest against the invasion
in kerrson in verdyansk in malitopol
they are waving their blue and yellow
flags in the faces of the occupying
soldiers
and they haven't stopped even after
russian soldiers have beaten them and
shot some of them down
honorable members if freedom has a name
its name is ukraine and the ukrainian
flag is the flag of freedom today
[Applause]
all our efforts are aimed at making this
war a strategic failure for putin
and this is why member states agreed to
assign 1 billion euros for security
assistance to the brave ukrainian
fighters
but supporting ukraine also means
draining the resources that putin is
using to finance his atrocious war
last week we decided on a fourth package
of unprecedented sanctions
we are denying russia the status of most
favored nation
and severely restricting its access to
our markets
because russia should not benefit
from the very same rules-based order
that it is so grossly violating
we are stopping new european investment
across russia's energy sector
because we should not be reinforcing the
energy dependency that we want to put
behind us
we continue to pressure russian elites
close to putin by hunting down their
yachts prestigious villas and expensive
cars
because those who sustain putin's war
should not be able to enjoy the lavish
lifestyle while bombs are falling on
ukraine
these measures come on top of three
other packages of sanctions they are
already biting hard into the russian
economy
the rubble has plummeted to an all-time
low earlier this month
interest rates are above 20 percent
rating agencies have downgraded russian
bonds to junk status
hundreds of global companies are leaving
russia because they don't want to feed
putin's war of choice
this honorable members
is the legacy that putin will leave
behind in russia he has become the worst
enemy of the russian people too
[Applause]
but first and foremost
he is responsible for the human tragedy
in ukraine
until now more than three million people
have left ukraine
half of them children
every second
a child from ukraine arrives in our
union every second
so while i'm speaking to you here in the
heart of the european democracy
800 children are leaving ukraine
courageous
traumatized and in need of help
they leave behind their brothers and
fathers not knowing whether they will
see them again
and it is heartening to see the
pan-european wave of solidarity for our
ukrainian friends i applaud the enormous
generosity of all europeans all member
states and moldova
at the european level we will mobilize
massive resources to support member
states hosting people fleeing the war
we've made sure that the regional
development and cohesion funds and react
to you can be used with the greatest
flexibility so that cities and regions
can invest in schools housing and health
care and many many thanks for your
support i just saw this is up to 17
billion that we are moving now many
thanks to you but i think this is not
enough
we now propose to accelerate
3.4 billion euros to front load
liquidity to our member states that are
showing such
exceptional solidarity so i count on you
honorable members to green light this
money quickly this will send a strong
message of our common commitment to
supporting the ukrainian people
and honorable members
we should be clear-eyed about what lies
ahead of us
and i'm not just talking about security
in military terms
but also energy security and even food
security are at stake
so let me start with energy
energy policy is also security policy
and that's why the commission has
proposed measures
that would allow us to significantly
reduce our gas imports from russia
this is very ambitious
but we can achieve it
we have already set a clear path to do
this and we are now accelerating
with our new proposal repower eu we can
speed up this transition even more
first by fast tracking renewable
projects this is a strategic investment
in our security including hydrogen and
biogas
second by speeding up investment in
energy efficiency everyone can
contribute in reducing our dependency on
russian gas
and third
by diversifying our gas supply away from
russian gas towards reliable suppliers
tomorrow i will discuss with president
biden how to prioritize lng deliveries
from the united states to the european
union in the coming months
we are aiming at having a commitment for
additional supplies for the next two
winters
honorable members
we are stronger when we use the power of
our single market and deliver solidarity
and in that spirit
we have just presented proposals to
jointly tackle one of our root causes of
the energy crisis
and these are the high and volatile gas
prices
we are proposing common gas procurement
and stricter rules for storage
because instead of outbidding each other
and driving prices up
we should pull our common weight and
start buying gas together as european
not 20 different 27 different member
states and in addition
in addition we should use our gas
storage facilities and some member
states of our union to secure the gas
supplies everywhere in our union
this will not only benefit the member
states whose tanks are
who where those tanks are located but
also their neighbors
take the baltics for example lithuania
has one of the biggest lng terminals in
the region
while latvia boasts massive underground
storage facilities so already today
lngas arriving in cal clipeda
is used to fill storage facilities in
latvia and of course customers in
neighboring estonia benefit as well this
is the way to go
and finally
the effects of the russian war go beyond
energy of course
they are also disrupting vital food
supplies and driving food prices up
the european union has assigned at least
2.5 billion euros until 2024 to help
regions across the world facing food
insecurity
and this morning we decided on a wide
range of special measures to help
european farmers
we will table a package of 500 million
euros to support those most affected by
the crisis
we should not forget that ukraine alone
provides more than half
of the world food programs wheat supply
the shelling and the bombing makes it
impossible for ukrainian farmers to sow
on top of that
putin is blocking hundreds of ships
filled with wheat in the black sea
so the consequences will be felt from
lebanon egypt and tunisia to africa and
the far east
and i call on putin to let those ships
go otherwise he will not only be
responsible for warren death but also
for famine and hunger let these ships go
honourable members
tonight will mark the first month of the
russian invasion
since the very first day
europe has stood united and let's
continue to do so
if there's anything that putin did not
anticipate then it's our unity the speed
of our action and our determination he
should be no doubt that we will stay the
course long live unity and long live
europe thank you
[Music]
thank you very much
president